what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and disney's disney plus
day and disney's d23 event is right
around the corner where we can expect to
get some major reveals of marvel studios
as phase six and perhaps even some
surprise projects for phase five as well
there's always the possibility that they
haven't showed us all of phase five and
they're saving some for these two big
events no doubt some huge projects are
coming like deadpool 3 hopefully the
x-men which we are going to talk about
in this video and other projects like
nova the future is exciting however at
san diego comic-con this year marvel
studios did reveal two insanely huge
projects avengers the kang dynasty and
not too long after that avengers secret
wars and these two movies are going to
be unlike any other movies that we've
ever seen in the mcu so far and there's
a few reasons why and mostly it's
actually because of the villains now
obviously we know that one of the big
bads of the mcu right now is king the
conqueror king the conqueror or i should
say a variant of king the conqueror was
introduced in loki as he who remains he
explained how all of his other variants
initially started a huge multiversal war
and he himself alone harnessed the power
of eliath and ended the multiversal war
then he created the tva and the sacred
timeline and kept all of his other evil
variants away however he did tell loki
and sylvie that if they killed him all
of his evil variants would be unleashed
and that's what happened and that's what
we're about to see in ant-man and the
wasp quantomania and then in the king
dynasty however there is another villain
lurking out there who is about to enter
the mcu pretty soon and that is dr doom
and i specifically believe that we are
going to see a version of god emperor
doom in secret wars however i do think
that dr doom is going to be somewhat of
a good guy at least at first when he's
introduced to the marvel cinematic
universe i think he'll start off as good
but you'll kind of have this hunch and
marvel will lead you to believe that
there is sort of a darker side to him
and that perhaps he could have some
ulterior motives now the villains these
two specifically kang and doctor doom
and some of the aspects that come with
these villains are going to be why these
two new avengers films are going to be
so incredible one is the multiverse is
going to be a major part of these two
movies and variants are going to be a
huge part of this film as well now right
off the bat i mentioned deadpool and
mutants i think everybody knows that
we're going to have a ton of different
variants and avengers secret wars at
least hopefully we start to see some
variants in the mcu before then but we
know that they're going to show up in
secret wars that's really what the movie
is about in the comics secret wars is
about incursion two universes colliding
into each other this is something that
we learned about in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness but is a huge
part in the comics of secret wars as
well so universes collide and through
incursion and universes colliding we are
going to get a bunch of different
variants of characters all together so
of course we'll have some people from
the avengers the fantastic four the
defenders and of course the x-men now
i've heard something recently about the
x-men there's a rumor going around that
deadpool when he enters the mcu is going
to be bringing some of his friends with
him and yes i am talking about domino
and cable but i'm also talking about
some other friends as well possibly from
the x-mansion right now rumor has it
that some x-men characters might
actually not be recast from the fox
universe but they will simply bring some
over into our universe from the fox
universe and they will remain the same
this is both pretty cool but also kind
of concerning because we don't have any
idea on which x-men characters they're
going to be bringing over and not
recasting there were a lot of problems
with the fox x-men towards the end there
but it wasn't really the actors fault
and some of them played pretty good
roles so if we get some characters like
michael fassbender's magneto that would
be pretty dang cool however there are
some characters that we would like to be
recast and i'm pretty sure hugh
jackman's wolverine isn't coming with
deadpool although that would be pretty
epic but that is the x-men rumor that
i've heard we'll see what happens in the
end regardless the x-men in some way
shape or form whether it's old
characters or new x-men in our marvel
cinematic universe are indeed going to
be in secret wars now here's the thing i
actually think dr doom is going to kill
kang and get rid of a lot of his
variants you see kang and doctor doom
are both so dangerous because they're
both so intelligent yes they are both
super powerful in their own ways kang
has technology that is so far advanced
that we can't really comprehend right
now and dr doom in the comics is an
extremely powerful sorcery but they're
both incredibly intelligent this is what
makes them so dangerous specifically i
think this is how god emperor doom will
come about i'll explain more in just a
bit but first thank you to best fiends
for sponsoring this video i think we all
know how much pressure life can put on
us sometimes and i know it's really easy
to put off having a little bit of
relaxation time and a little bit of fun
but that shouldn't be how it is and with
best fiends and exciting puzzle
adventure game you can have fiendish fun
anywhere anytime best fiends is an
awesome puzzle game that i truly enjoy
because it's not just connecting in
straight lines but you can actually
connect diagonally which is a lot more
fun and you can play at any time because
it's super quick to play and you level
up very very easily in fact the first
time i played it for only a few minutes
i got all the way to level 6. that's
because this game is really easy to just
pick up and get in the zone because it's
super fun one second you're on level one
and then the next thing you know you've
connected enough times to get to level
six and there are literally thousands of
different levels you can play and the
best part is best fiends is free to
download so don't put off your fun time
anymore you've definitely earned it go
to the app store or google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's best fiends without the r
now back to god emperor doom avengers
the kang dynasty is obviously going to
be about kang and not just one version
of kang but many different variants of
kang this has already been confirmed by
kevin feige and other executives at
marvel studios but avengers the kang
dynasty and avengers secret wars are
kind of like a part 1 and a part 2.
they're kind of like avengers infinity
war and avengers end game so at the end
of the kang dynasty something major has
to happen and what i think is going to
happen is that doom is going to kill a
major variant of kang take his
technology and use that to time travel
all throughout time the past the present
and definitely the future and use time
travel to essentially gain anything that
he wants weapons technology learn more
about sorcery the reason that kang is so
powerful is that he can control time and
if you can control time you can
essentially stop time so basically doom
has all the time in the world if he gets
his hands on kang's technology to learn
and become more powerful and again like
i mentioned in the comics he's an
insanely powerful sorcerer we saw how
strong wanda got simply by studying the
darkhold for a little bit imagine how
strong doctor doom is going to get in
the mcu if he has an unlimited amount of
time he has all of that time to learn
and to gain new technology this is what
makes kang so dangerous he has very
advanced technology and he can see
what's going to happen now take all of
that and give it to one of the most
powerful sorcerers that marvel comics
has ever seen doctor doom well you
pretty much get god emperor doom now of
course i know this is not the same god
emperor doom from the comics but marvel
studios doesn't really adapt comics page
for page as we know they're basically
just inspired by the stories and i don't
think the beyonder is going to be
showing up in avengers secret wars in
the mcu i don't think it's time for that
yet but we'll have to wait and see now
dr doom is known for tricking people in
the comics and that is how i believe he
is going to get his hands on king's
technology i actually think doom is
going to be tricking both the avengers
and other heroes and king and of course
it's to get what he wants all about him
of course he's going to trick the
avengers by making them think that he is
fighting along their side trying to
defeat king so they can save the
universe and the multiverse but then i
think he's going to tell kang that he
really wants to work with him and that
he'll betray the avengers when really
he's going to betray everybody i believe
that he's going to get a little bit
close with king learn a little bit about
his time travel and then steal a device
from him that enables him to control
time himself and that is how i believe
that doom is going to become the most
powerful villain that we've ever seen in
the marvel cinematic universe a sorcerer
who in the comics has the ability to
take on galactus combined with time
travel technology that allows you to
travel through the multiverse pretty
much makes you a god and that's how i
believe we're going to get the mcu's
version of god emperor doom but don't
take king likely just because god
emperor doom could trick kang doesn't
mean that kang is down and out if kang
is not killed and let's face it kang
can't really ever be killed because he
has so many different variants and can
transfer his consciousness into them
right before he dies that means that he
could always come back and i believe in
secret wars we'll have a doom versus
kang battle which means the avengers are
kind of going to have to pick a side at
least at first so i think in the kang
dynasty they're going to go up against
kang but at the end doom is ultimately
going to take king's power and then
secret wars become the true villain in
which i think they're going to have to
team up with some variants of kang to
defeat doom but let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu content for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof